we are living in today
but the last few days have told us
is that if there was ever any doubt
it should now be clear that no one no
one
is safe from this terrible pandemic
doesn't matter if you are a frontline
worker in a hospital and today we thank
all of the doctors and nurses and
medical personnel
for the extraordinary sacrifices they
have made
and in some cases given up their lives
for
us in this pandemic and it doesn't
matter
if you are an essential worker critical
worker at a supermarket
helping us get the food that we need
or a bus driver if you're a worker in a
meatpacking plant
and it doesn't matter if you are the
president
of the united states of america each and
every one of us
is vulnerable and we will remain
vulnerable until there is a
vaccine or a perfected
cure that is the reality that we face
and there is no getting away from that
now there are some who say that we have
to make a choice
between having a strong economy on one
hand
and protecting the american people from
this terrible disease
on the other hand i disagree
the truth is that we will never have
a strong economy so long
as this pandemic continues to surge
we will never have a strong economy
if people are afraid to go to work
if people are afraid to go to school
if people are afraid to shop
or go out to a restaurant or afraid to
do
all of the things that have always
been done we will never
have a strong economy unless
we get this pandemic under
control is the solution
to this crisis to shut down the economy
and lock everyone in their homes no
it is not we can keep
our country moving forward
if we do so in a way that is disciplined
not dangerous that is responsible
not reckless and if
we listen to the science
[Applause]
and now importantly
i want you to take a moment
and to ask yourselves some very simple
questions and i really want you to think
about your answers because there is
probably no issue out there
more important than this which
candidate for president has shown
that he will be disciplined that he will
be
responsible that he will do his best to
protect the people
around him as we deal with this pandemic
and the answer is joe biden
which candidate for president has made
it clear
that he will develop policies
which are based on science not
politics and that he will seek
the advice of the best scientists and
doctors
in our country and around
the world in order to combat and defeat
this pandemic and the answer
to that question is joe biden
which candidate for president will
develop strong
national protocols and guidelines
and model the behaviors we all need
to engage in to keep our families our
co-workers
and our neighbors safe
and the answer is joe biden
which candidate has the temperament
to see us through this unprecedented
moment the worst public health crisis
in over 100 years and let me repeat that
question
which candidate has the temperament
to see us through this difficult
crisis i don't think there is any doubt
that the answer to that question is
joe biden
and my friends that is why
we need joe biden as our next
president and now let me
say if i might a special word
to the young people of our country
during the last year and a half
i have had the extraordinary opportunity
to travel all across this country in
almost every state
in the union and what i have learned
is that the young generation in our
country today
black and whites latino native american
asian american is an extraordinarily
beautiful group of people
it is the most progressive the most
compassionate
the most open-minded young generation
in the history of our country
it is a generation that thinks
big not small and
is prepared for a new vision
as to what our country can
and must become
and that vision is based
on the principles of justice
economic justice racial
social justice environmental
justice
this is a generation that is leading the
fight
against systemic racism
and police brutality it is a generation
that is leading the fight against
xenophobia a generation that is leading
the fight
against sexism a generation that is
leading the fight
against religious bigotry a generation
that is leading the fight
against never-ending wars
and a bloated military budget
and this is a generation
unlike the current president of the
united states
that knows that climate change
is real that it is imperative
that we stand up to the fossil fuel
industry
and that we are going to need bold
action in order to create a planet
that will be healthy for our children
and grandchildren this generation
younger generation
understands all of that
[Applause]
but and here is the button
as wonderful and idealistic as our young
generation is it has one major
political shortcoming
and that political shortcoming is
that that this young generation
does not vote in large enough
numbers the voter turnout among young
people has improved
in the last few years but it still
has a very long way to go
so today i say to the young people here
in michigan
and around the country if you are
worried about the outrageous
level of student debt that many of you
are incurring if you are upset
about the high cost of college in
graduate school
if you are concerned about the
low-paying jobs
that many of you have if you are
concerned and worried about climate
change
sexism racism homophobia and religious
bigotry
it is not enough to complain
or to moan and grow we got to fight
back and the first way is to vote
and not only to vote but to vote
in record-breaking numbers
and let me say this again to the younger
generation
that if you vote at the same percentages
as older people in this country vote not
only will biden win this election
we will transform this country
the future of america depends upon you
[Applause]
now all over this country as many of you
know
in many republican controlled states and
this makes me really
very sad officials
in a variety of ways are trying to
suppress
the vote they're cowardly
they are trying to make it harder for
working people poor people
people of color and young people to vote
they want a low voter turnout
because they think that will help them
politically
fortunately that is
not the case here in michigan
in michigan not only has early voting
already begun in every township in the
state but
you can still register to vote
online until october 19th
and in person until election day
same day registration in other words
you can vote or register to vote
right now no matter where you live in
the state
in addition uh
there are opening today
new polling sites near three college
campuses
east lansing near msu
as well as on campus at western michigan
university
and northern michigan university
excuse me further detroit
is opening 21 early voting sites
across the city which will be open
seven days a week until
election day
[Applause]
my friends this is the most important
election
in the modern history of our country
it is imperative that joe biden wins
that we have a democratic house
including
debbie dingle and that we have
a democratic senate including
your senator gary peters who must be
reelected
now i don't have to remind anyone here
or in michigan
that in 2016 donald trump
won this state and its 16 electoral
votes
by two tenths of one percent
two tenths of one percent of one percent
the stakes are just too
high we cannot allow that
to happen again
so if anybody has doubts about whether
their vote
matters remember what happened
in 2016 10 000 votes
in michigan so your vote matters
in fact it can be decisive in
determining
the future not only here in michigan
but because you are a major battleground
state
what happens here can well determine
the future of the entire united states
of america
and now let me say a word as to why
this election is so so very important
and i don't have to tell anyone that the
young people
in our country have been dealt some
extraordinarily
odd blows throughout their young lives
in fact young americans have now lived
through the two worst economic crises
since the great depression of the
nineteen thirties
twelve years ago young people all over
this country had to deal with the wall
street crash
that caused millions of americans to
lose their jobs
lose their homes and lose their life
savings
and many have never fully recovered
from that crash of 12 years ago and
today
right now young people are being hit
by the massive economic downturn
caused by the covet 19 pandemic
during this pandemic right now 54
of young americans under the age of 29
have either lost the job or had to take
a pay cut
more than any other age group
52 percent of young americans have been
forced to move back home
with their parents 35 of young americans
have had problems finding enough money
to pay for rent
medical bills or other expenses
unless we reverse costs
everything being equal the younger
generation
will for the first time in the modern
history of our country
have a lower standard of living
than their parents because this country
right now
is experiencing massive downward
mobility we want to go up not down
young americans today are making less
money than their parents did
when they entered the workforce they
have smaller savings accounts
they are less likely to own their own
homes as the cost of housing has gone
up and up and up they are drowning in
student debt
for what reason that they chose to do
the right thing and get a college
education and even though young workers
are more likely than ever
to have a college degree the jobs they
have
on not paying them the wages or salaries
they need
to have an adequate standard of living
and many of the jobs
they have been that they have have been
hard
hit by the pandemic
a majority of bartenders in america are
young
half of all restaurant workers in
america
are young a huge percentage of the
retail
sector is filled with young people and
these are precisely the industries
that have been hit the hardest by the
economic downturn
in other words while many millions of
young people are struggling to pay off
outrageous high levels of student debt
many of them are forced to work for
wages
that are much too low if
they are lucky enough to have a job at
all and if we do not get our act
together soon
this very bad situation will become
even worse because according to the
department of labor
the occupations that will create the
most jobs in america over the next
decade
are home health care aides fast food
workers and cooks
jobs that pay low wages and don't
require
a college degree
let me be as clear as i can possibly be
and that is
that in the richest country in the
history of the world
we have got to do better than that
we need to create an economy
and a government that work for all of
us not just for one percent and wealthy
campaign contributors
now it is no secret no great secret at
all that joe biden and i
have differences of opinion and as
united states senate up
make no mistake about it i will continue
to fight for the principles that i have
advocated
for a very long time i ain't going away
but i also want to tell you that in
fairness
joe if his campaign
proposals were to be implemented
they would significantly improve the
lives
of tens of millions of working families
and would make joe biden the most
progressive president
of the united states since franklin
delano roosevelt
and frankly i don't think our campaign
has done a good enough job
in talking about what joe is fighting
for so let me take a few minutes to do
that
when joe biden is president this is what
is
clearly in his state of principles
when joe is president he will make
public colleges
universities and trade schools tuition
free for working families
and he will substantially reduce student
debt
in america under joe's plan if you
attended a four-year public college or
university
and you earn less than 125 000
a year he will cancel your student
debt
joe understands that every working class
and middle class young person
should be able to get a higher education
regardless of the income of their
families
unlike the current president joe biden
understands that climate change is real
that it is caused by human activity and
that we have got
to move aggressively to transform
our energy system and that is why
joe is proposing two trillion dollars
to transform our energy system away from
fossil fuel
towards energy efficiency and
sustainable energy
and by the way when we make
that investment we create millions
of good paying jobs in this country
[Applause]
and when we talk about the need to raise
wages
in america let's be clear
when joe biden is president we are going
to raise
the federal minimum wage from the
starvation wage
of seven and a quarter an hour to a
living wage
of at least 15 dollars an hour
joe understands that if you work 40
hours a week
you should not be living in poverty
and joe also understands that it is
absurd
that women in america are earning
80 cents on the dollar compared
to men joe believes you believe and i
believe
equal pay for equal work
and joe also knows that if we are going
to expand the middle class in this
country
we must make it easier for workers to
join
unions
to engage in collective bargaining and
to end
the heavy-handed corporate tactics that
make it so hard
for workers to unionize in our country
and joe biden also understands
that we have got to stop providing
corporate
welfare to companies that are throwing
american workers
out on the street and moving to low-wage
countries around the world
[Applause]
when joe is president he will sign an
executive order
to prevent companies that ship american
jobs overseas
from receiving a nickel in corporate
welfare
and i'll tell you what joe biden also
understands
and what all of you know to be true
and that is we have got to end the
international embarrassment of the
united states being the
only major country on earth not to
guarantee
paid medical and family leave
how absurd is it how absurd is it that
the wealthiest country in the world
cannot guarantee paid family and medical
leave
to its workers when a woman in this
country gives birth
she should not be forced to go back to
work
after one or two weeks
when a child gets sick when a child gets
sick
mom or dad should be able to stay home
and not lose
a day's pay and that is why
joe biden has proposed at least
12 weeks of paid family and medical
leave
for working families in our country
and when we talk about little kids
and young children we all know
that our current child care system
is a disgrace and is totally
inadequate our children and their
parents
deserve high quality reliable
and affordable child care and that is
why joe
has proposed universal
pre-k education for every three
and four-year-old in the country
[Applause]
some of you may recall
early in this campaign
i traveled to canada with a group
of diabetics uh
to buy insulin a life
and death drug for more than
30 million americans and in fact
that trip with diabetics began
in detroit michigan
and here is what we found on that trip
and it's something i will
never forget and that is you can go
15 miles into canada
and you can buy insulin there for
one tenth of the price
that it is sold here in the united
states
no you didn't mishear me i said you can
buy
insulin in canada for one tenth
of the price that it is hold here
same company same product
one tenth of the price and it's not just
canada and it's not just insulin
while the drug companies through their
collusion
through their price fixing and through
their greed
make obscene profits every year
we end up paying by far the highest
prices
in the world for prescription drugs
one out of five americans who get a
prescription from a doctor
cannot afford to fill that prescription
how insane is that joe biden
understands that we finally
must have the courage to take on the
greed of the pharmaceutical industry
and lower the outrageous prices of
prescription drugs
in this country
as i think many of you know the united
states
is the only major country on earth not
to guarantee health care for all people
as a human right meanwhile
despite paying almost twice as much
per capita for health care as the people
of other countries
over 90 million americans today
are uninsured or underinsured
and almost a half a million americans go
bankrupt because they cannot afford
to pay their medical bills and i'll tell
you something else
an outrage beyond belief
that because of the high cost of health
care in america
some 60 000 of our people
die every single year
because they don't get to a doctor when
they're sick they just can't afford to
walk into
a doctor's office how outrageous is that
now joe and i disagree on the best path
to get to universal coverage i believe
in medicare
for all
[Music]
[Applause]
but while joe and i disagree
i know that he will greatly expand
access
to health care and make it more
affordable
for tens of millions of people across
this country
he will make sure that everyone in
america
has access to a public option
similar to medicare he will lower the
eligibility age
of medicare from 65
to 60 no small thing
he will expand medicare to cover dental
care
and eyeglasses and hearing aids
and he will substantially
increase funding for community health
centers
to make sure that millions of americans
get the primary health care
and mental health care that they
desperately need
joe understands as you understand as i
understand as debbie dingle
understands that when you talk about
health care
it's not just cancer and a broken leg
it is mental health care as well
joe biden also understands understands
that we must
end systemic racism in this country
and that we cannot continue to have more
people in jail
than any other country on earth
and that is why joe will end private
prisons in america
and private detention centers and that
is why
we will make sure that no one in america
sits in a jail cell because they are too
poor
to afford cash bail instead of more
jails and incarceration
joe understands that we need
more jobs and more education
joe biden also understands that we
are a nation of immigrants my dad
came to this country at the age of 17
and that we cannot continue to terrorize
and demonize over 11 million
undocumented people in america and that
is why
and that is why joe has proposed a
comprehensive
immigration reform plan and a path
toward citizenship for the undocumented
that is why he will provide legal status
to the 1.8 million young people
eligible for the daca program and that
is why he will end the disastrous
ice raids and develop a humane
border policy for those who seek asylum
no more snatching babies from the arms
of their mothers
my friends in this unprecedented moment
in american history let us reject those
who want to divide us up
based on the color of our skin
or our religion or our sexual
orientation
or the country of our birth
let us come together as never before
black and white latino
asian american native american
gay and straight those of us who were
born in this country
those of us who immigrated here
let us come together to elect
a democratic congress
let us come together to enact the most
progressive agenda in the modern history
of this country
let us come together to build an america
that works for
all and not just the billionaire class
and let us elect joe biden
as the next president of the united
states of america
thank you all very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you